yo quiero empezar contándoles que yo
tengo muy pocas memorias de mi infancia
pero las que tengo son muy puntuales más
o menos a los 89 años de edad yo
recuerdo estar en la cafetería del
colegio de mi escuela esto en el
salvador en donde nací
a la hora de comer celebrada por mis
compañeros ellos me abrazaban me
aplaudían porque me había comido un
dulce de guayaba que me habían puesto en
la lonchera
esta celebración se debía a que
aparentemente yo tenía varios días sin
comer
para ese mismo año yo necesitaba unas
hojas sueltas de papel para colocar
encima de mis cuadernos esto era más o
menos cuarto de primaria para no mojar
mi trabajo porque a mí me sudaba mucho
las manos cuando ya empezaba a diseñar
el que posiblemente sería mi vestido de
novia el que quizás algún día me pondría
para esa época era estilo cenicienta se
acuerdan redondo con unos lazos que le
hacían así
mi mayor preocupación era que si para
esa época porque faltaba mucho tiempo
y van a estar o no de moda los guantes
si serían de encaje largos cortitos
porque a mí sin duda me ayudarían las
manos y qué vergüenza llegar hacia el
altar
se la imaginan sin comer
este patrón de comer desordenadamente o
de sudar bajo ciertos niveles de estrés
se quedó conmigo no identificado como
tal por largo rato
y lo que pasa es que yo no soy una
persona que se considera que se estresa
mucho
yo más bien tiendo a querer buscar la
lección detrás de lo que me pasa
o preguntar cuál es mi parte cuando
tengo un conflicto con otra persona
no soy una persona con energía nerviosa
a mí la ansiedad generalmente no se me
nota
sin embargo este patrón no era un patrón
aislado no era un patrón que me hace
sentir sola porque como mujeres
generalmente tenemos compañía en temas
de la comida no me dejarán mentir
según el instituto nacional de salud
mental es una organización gubernamental
en eeuu a las mujeres nos afectan los
trastornos alimenticios dos veces más
que a los hombres
bueno eventualmente después de que llegó
a considerar si posiblemente estas
señales de la comida o del sudor tenían
algo que ver con mis emociones realice
esa conexión por primera vez porque este
tiempo coincidía con la ruptura de mi
familia y la separación de mis padres
más adelante me mudo eeuu y sigo un
camino ordenado socialmente aceptado me
graduó de comunicación y periodismo
porque yo incluso de este cuarto grado
soñaba y sabía que mi destino era
conducir un programa de televisión
y consigo una pasantía en una de las
cadenas de televisión más importantes de
eeuu de esa pasantía yo derivo mi primer
trabajo en los medios y me quedo ahí
calladita dijéramos por casi 20 años
bárbara kirk a gran puesto que tiene
viven como areva de bien ascensiones
periódicamente buenos mentores social
estable novia de un buen muchacho
hasta resalta de vez en cuando porque
como ella es extrovertida aquí entrenos
yo realmente soy introvertida
y no le da pena hablar en público ni
tampoco ser la primera en la pista de
baile en las bodas
y bueno
no es que todo eso no era cierto
pero llega un momento en el que me lo
cuestioné por esa conexión que acababa
de realizar hace un tiempo a pocos días
de un cumpleaños significativo me
encontré una de esas tantas mañanas
sentadas frente a esa cámara que tanto
adoro y me hice una pregunta escuchar
una voz dentro de mí que me decía que si
yo quería cumplir mi próxima
significativa década sentada allí mismo
con esos tacones que solo me ponían para
la tele bajo estas luces y esas cámaras
que tanto disfrutó en compañía de gente
buena sin duda buenos amigos gente
divertida que hacía que valiera la pena
madrugar cada mañana
y la respuesta que escuche dentro de mí
me sorprendió muchísimo porque escuché
que había más para mí
esto no tiene ningún sentido cómo es
posible yo estaba clara desde muy
temprana edad mi propósito estaba claro
yo sabía que yo quería comunicar para el
desarrollo personal
y entonces me pregunto
realmente qué es lo que está pasando con
esta fórmula que hasta este momento ha
cuadrado y entonces me tardó dos años en
armar me del valor necesario para tomar
una decisión importante de un cambio
significativo me canso los oídos a mis
amigas meditó rezo visualizó 27 mil
mapas de la prosperidad
todos buscando ese valor que me hacía
falta para tomar esa decisión importante
y finalmente lo logró tomo una decisión
la más incómoda de mi vida dándome
cuenta y comprobando que incomodó no es
sinónimo de desacertado
bueno aplicó también una lección sobre
el miedo que es la más impactante que yo
jamás haya escuchado tan impactante que
se las quiero compartir y es que en el
antiguo hebreo del viejo testamento hay
dos palabras para miedo
una de estas palabras es la palabra paja
este sentimiento esta sensación es el
miedo a lo proyectado oa lo imaginado es
el miedo que se imagina lo peor que
puede pasar
es lo que responde a ese instinto que
como seres humanos tenemos de luchar o
huir
pero también hay otra palabra la palabra
lira
qué es la sensación que se siente frente
a lo sagrado lo describen quizás como lo
que sentimos cuando estamos sobre tierra
santa
es una sensación que sentimos cuando
recibimos más energía de la que quizás
teníamos previamente o habitamos un
espacio más grande del que estamos
acostumbrados a habitar
en mi caso estaba claro como el agua que
sin duda era la segunda la que yo estaba
experimentando porque yo me moría de
este presunto miedo pero también me
embargaba una emoción y una sensación de
no aguantarme por ver qué es lo que
estaba del otro lado
entonces sin todas las respuestas
con muy poca claridad me armé de ese
valor
para renunciar
renuncié a mi audiencia renuncie a la
posibilidad de por lo menos en los
próximos años ganarme otros premios emmy
renuncie a hacer que ir a la de la tele
según la investigadora pei brown
la valentía el valor es sinónimo de
vulnerabilidad
dos conceptos que van de la mano que no
es generalmente lo que pensamos porque
solemos pensar sobre la vulnerabilidad
como algo negativo y sobre el valor como
algo positivo una no se puede dar sin la
otra
y la vulnerabilidad o este valor del que
yo en este momento me doy cuenta que me
armo
responde a tres factores según esta
investigación
la incertidumbre
el riesgo y el estar dispuestos a
exponernos emocionalmente cuando hacemos
algo con valentía estamos aceptando la
posibilidad de una de estas tres cosas o
incluso todas juntas a la vez como fue
mi caso
al tomar esa decisión y ver tan
claramente que yo había hecho algo con
valentía me doy cuenta me percato de que
yo tenía mucho tiempo
evadiendo precisamente
esas tres cosas mientras yo ejercía bajo
la seguridad a mis talentos porque me
sentía muy cómoda sobre esa plataforma
que había elegido
yo no me atrevía realmente a ser
vulnerable en mi vida
me escondía de esa vulnerabilidad como
yo primero muerta que mis amigos me
vieran en traje de baño
o ponerme una manga corta porque el
brazo podría estar muy gordo
equivocarme a leer un guión a pesar de
ser televisión en vivo
no pedir un aumento de salario en casi
una década de trabajo
no aprovechar una oportunidad de
producir mi propio programa de
televisión cuando se me da la
oportunidad
o algo tan sencillo más divertido que no
atreverme a bailar en tarima con mi
grupo de salsa yo mejor renuncie antes
del día desde el día del show
deja pasar muchas oportunidades de
crecer de gozar de servir a través de mi
talento
pero bueno me había dado cuenta de que
era hora de armar me de valor y de hacer
un cambio sin duda alguna todavía estaba
a tiempo
para mi sorpresa con esta decisión tan
difícil tan importante en mi vida yo
perdí la voz por completo
y nada de esto tenía sentido quién era
yo sin ese estudio sin un equipo de
producción sin gente que necesitaba que
yo hablara por ellos ahora tenía que
hablar por mí y no tenía nada que decir
pasaban meses paralizada y no conseguía
el valor suficiente ni para hablar en
redes sociales
las oportunidades de trabajo venían
hacia mí gracias a las personas que
reconocen mi talento y a todas esas
personas yo debía decirles ahora no no
estoy lista más adelante quizás
y el tiempo seguía pasando y entonces me
pregunto qué es lo que es este mentado
propósito del que tanto venimos hablando
particularmente yo que lo había
convertido la esencia de mi trabajo mi
eslogan es
descubre vive y comparte tu don porque
es único porque yo de verdad considero
estoy convencida de que cada uno de
nosotros tiene uno o más dones que
solamente nosotros con nuestro arte y a
nuestra manera podemos compartir con el
mundo y eso es lo que el mundo necesita
que cada uno de nosotros haga
precisamente eso
voy a compartirles un ciclo que me ayudó
a darme cuenta de por qué yo estaba
buscando el propósito en el lugar
equivocado
yo que había presuntamente identificado
mi propósito a muy temprana edad
desde que recorría los foros de
televisión con mi mamá que trabajaba
precisamente en estudios de televisión
resultaba que yo que me creía tan
identificada con mi misión de vida me
había dado cuenta de que me hacía falta
algo sumamente importante y les voy a
compartir esta lección que es lo que me
ha devuelto la voz nosotros nacemos como
una creación perfecta
los que han tenido hijos saben que
cuando ese bebé llega a nuestras manos y
los que no cuando han recibido a lo
mejor el bebé de un ser querido un
familiar sabemos que esa criaturita
tiene dentro de sí todo lo necesario
para merecer así tal cual amor
incondicional
después la vida pasa
y en la mayoría de los casos sufrimos el
trauma el trauma puede llegar a todos
los colores no quiero que se me asusten
para que no se identifique con algo
puntual porque porque el trauma puede
ser obvio como puede ser ambiguo puede
ser puntual de un instante o puede ser
de la mitad de tu vida puede ser severo
o leve por al final es completamente
válido y lo importante de reconocerlo es
que la sensación que nos da el trauma o
esto que nos pasa en la vida es sin duda
alguna doloroso difícil e incómodo
y como es natural porque nuestro cerebro
está programado para salvaguardar
nuestra supervivencia no para hacernos
felices tomamos un desvío
yo me voy a alejar de esto que es
incómodo difícil o doloroso y nos vamos
separando lentamente de nuestra esencia
de lo quiénes realmente somos y nos
queremos desconectar
como nos desconectamos anestesiando esos
sentimientos quiero preguntarle si
alguno se identifica con comportamientos
como comerse medio bizcocho de chocolate
de una sentada
como perderse en un mundo alterno a
través de netflix por nueve horas
seguidas
cómo mantenerse en relaciones tóxicas
porque nos aportan placer temporal
o alterar nuestra imagen para acoplarnos
a estándares que nosotros creemos son
los que la gente espera de nosotros
nos ponemos en las redes sociales unas
máscaras según esos lineamientos
ficticios nos sacamos grasa del cuerpo
con jeringas
o no nos atrevemos a decir lo que
queremos decir por miedo a de que no sea
bien recibido
ahora como también dijo bernie brown
el problema con esta fórmula es que no
podemos anestesiar los sentimientos de
manera selectiva
si pudiéramos fuéramos en coche tómate
esta pastillita para la tristeza porque
todavía puedes ser feliz o estar
presente en tu vida o fuma texto para la
ansiedad porque no te va a afectar la
líbido
lamentablemente como no es selectiva esa
decisión entonces nos vamos apagando
amputando vamos cambiando mimetizando y
vamos perdiendo cada vez más la
experiencia de nuestro ser
pero entonces si tenemos suerte un día
nos cuestionamos
a lo mejor
tenemos sobrepeso a lo mejor tenemos
incluso enfermedades crónicas o tenemos
rupturas familiares importantes o somos
miserables en el trabajo y algo nos hace
cuestionar esa fórmula de evasión y
desconexión que estamos que habíamos
elegido
entonces cómo es nuestra tendencia
empezamos a buscar hacia afuera porque
como civilización tenemos siglos
viviendo hacia afuera
cuando hacemos esta evaluación entonces
tomamos cursos vamos a retiros viajamos
a conferencias contratamos coaches y
psicólogos nos acercamos a la iglesia
nos volvemos dispuestos a buscar ese
propósito yo ya me cansé de trabajar en
el banco yo realmente lo que quiero es
ser artista yo nací para pintar
o yo me quiero parar en escenarios más
grandes y quiero que mi voz llegue un
poco más lejos
fue ahí en donde yo me di cuenta de que
me estaba tocando con la pared porque me
di cuenta de que estaba enfocándome en
solamente lo externo
y es que yo no me había atrevido a mirar
hacia adentro
porque aquí adentro lo que había era un
perfeccionismo paralizante
y ojo el perfeccionismo es el miedo
enmascarado al rechazo y al abandono
aquí adentro había un rechazo al peso o
el tamaño de mi cuerpo cuando se salía
de un marco que yo percibía como el
ideal
había una indisposición a tomar acción
imperfecta
y había uno que otro resentimiento
familiar
yo no estoy sola realmente lo sé en esa
realidad
los estudios nos lo comprueban por
ejemplo un estudio británico de la
revista ingenio 2014 demuestra que el 20
por ciento de los encuestados dicen que
no se hablan con algún miembro de la
familia me pregunto cuál sería esa cifra
si hiciéramos esa encuesta en este salón
más de dos mil millones de personas
tienen sobrepeso en el mundo y como
sabemos millones pasan por un proceso de
adicción o de recuperación de la
adicción
por lo que tenemos esta situación que es
prácticamente normal y es más solamente
hace falta conducir por cualquier ciudad
del mundo para darse cuenta de que la
insatisfacción es rampante
ahora
llega el momento
de la verdad
llega el momento en el que yo
me hago la pregunta verdadera y me doy
cuenta
de esta revelación que me ha devuelto la
oportunidad de estar aquí con ustedes
hoy y es que el secreto de cualquier
propósito de vida es que nuestro único
propósito irrefutable
es el de aceptarnos tal cual somos y de
amarnos incondicionalmente
porque hasta que no logremos esa
aceptación y la disponibilidad de hacer
eso como una renovación diaria
no tendremos el suelo firme sobre el
cual edificar ese otro propósito del que
tantos líderes y motivadores como yo les
hemos hablado
la aceptación incondicional de nosotros
mismos no es negociable
a pesar de que yo cuando tenía las
conversaciones con mis seres queridos y
tengo hablando de propósito varios años
a través de mi trabajo las
conversaciones siempre terminaban en es
pequeño no sé para qué soy bueno
o a mí no me apasiona nada me apasionan
muchas cosas o quién tiene lujo de
trabajar en lo que no es lo que le gusta
hay que ahorrar dinero hay que trabajar
bueno
por eso porque el propósito irrefutable
no tiene que ver con tu pasión trabajo o
servicio o hobby tiene que ver contigo
mismo primero
entonces hasta que logre este cambio
profundo y difícil
entendí que mi voz no tiene que ser la
mejor ni tiene que ser la más fuerte
ni tiene que ser la canosa equivoca
pero si es la voz que tienen que
escuchar algunas personas como parte de
su proceso de autodescubrimiento
yo estoy aquí para decirles que el
momento en el que ustedes encuentren esa
autoaceptación
será posible subirse en el escenario aún
cuando te suban las manos
gracias
[Aplausos]